This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at It播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在Outer、My Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界传递出一个信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。请在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格蕾丝，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我当时惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange model.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。
and worry. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
和担忧。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是TWO percent。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。请在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends》。
Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Today we are answering a question I have been having of myself recently. Why am I spending so much money? Specifically, why have I been using money to self-soothe to feel, better about my life, to take away bad feelings about the state of the world, probably more than I ever have. We're talking about a phenomenon that has been popping up all over social media in financial columns on TikTok, this concept of doom spending. I also think it's a great time to talk about money with the holidays coming up. The urge and the desire to spend, perhaps more than we have beyond our means is very, very strong within us.
大家好。我是杰玛·斯派克（Gemma Spike），欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个我们探讨20多岁时经历的最大变化、时刻和过渡期，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，正如我们所做的那样，我们当然要剖析20多岁时的心理。今天我们要回答一个我最近一直在问自己的问题。为什么我花了这么多钱？具体来说，为什么我一直在用金钱来自我安慰，为了对自己的生活感觉更好一点，为了消除对世界现状的负面情绪，这可能比我以往任何时候都要多。我们要讨论的是一种在社交媒体、金融专栏和TikTok上随处可见的现象，即“末日消费”这个概念。我也觉得现在是个谈论金钱的好时机，因为节日即将来临。那种消费的冲动和渴望，也许超出了我们的能力范围，在我们内心非常非常强烈。
And I want to talk about this specific type of compulsion, this specific reason why you and I, people in their 20s, are spending all this money on things that maybe we don't really need. Doom spending is basically the desire or the impulse to spend money more rapidly and in larger sums in response to our anxiety and uncertainty about the future. and about the world. It is this tendency to like live in the now to spend because the future is uncertain to treat ourselves. It's the use of money to manage our emotions. And you might be thinking like what is the problem with that? Like I work hard for my money. Surely I should be and you are allowed to
我想谈谈这种特定类型的强迫行为，谈谈为什么你和我，这些二十多岁的人，要把所有的钱都花在那些我们可能并不真正需要的东西上。末日消费基本上是指，为了应对我们对未来和世界的焦虑与不确定性，而更迅速、更大额度地花钱的渴望或冲动。这是一种活在当下的倾向，因为未来是不确定的，所以要犒劳自己。这是用金钱来管理我们的情绪。你可能会想，这有什么问题呢？我凭自己的本事赚钱。当然我应该，而且你也允许
spend it however I want. But there is a level where it actually gets out of control. It can begin to become a maladaptive coping mechanism and it can actually in a way feed into our pessimism about the future in a way that is a little bit unhealthy also you know it takes away from our ability to plan financially and to save and to achieve you know financial freedom financial sustainability to have long-term financial goals and although we may not be thinking about that in our early 20s or in our 20s at all, it is still an important conversation. So in this episode, we're going to talk about what doom spending actually is, why we do it, what it says about the times we're living in, and how to get control over how you spend money in a really healthy, gentle and I think sustainable way.
我想怎么花就怎么花。但某种程度上，它确实失控了。它开始演变成一种适应不良的应对机制，而且它实际上可能会以一种不太健康的方式助长我们对未来的悲观情绪。此外，你知道的，它削弱了我们在财务上进行规划、储蓄以及实现财务自由、财务可持续性并拥有长期财务目标的能力。尽管我们在刚满二十岁或整个二十多岁时可能根本不会去想这些，但这仍然是一个重要的对话。所以在这一期节目中，我们将讨论究竟什么是末日消费，我们为什么会这样做，它说明了我们生活的这个时代有什么特点，以及如何以一种真正健康、温和且我认为可持续的方式来掌控你的消费。
Without further ado, let's get into it. Let's begin with the basics. We always do this at the start every episode I feel like a broken record, but just so we have a clear definition of doom spending, what I'm talking about is not just spending because you feel like it. I'm talking about the use of spending often that's impulsive as a way to calm a sense of uncertainty or a threat. It is an emotional coping mechanism. It's not buying things that you actually need. It's not buying things that you know, you want and you feel like you should treat yourself to it is buying because the future doesn't feel like it's coming and so you want to live in the now and a way to feel better about perhaps the future not coming, which by the way it is, is to, you know, spend and to fill your
闲话少说，我们切入正题。让我们从基础开始。每期节目开始时我们都会这样做，我感觉自己就像个复读机，但为了让我们对末日消费有一个清晰的定义，我所说的不仅仅是因为你想花钱而花钱。我指的是将消费（通常是冲动消费）作为一种平息不确定感或威胁感的方式。这是一种情绪应对机制。它不是买你真正需要的东西。它不是买那些你知道自己想要并觉得自己应该犒劳一下自己的东西，而是因为觉得未来好像不会到来，所以你想活在当下，而为了对“未来可能不会到来”（顺便说一句，未来是会到来的）这种想法感觉好一点，你就会去消费，去填满你的
wardrobe and to get the dopamine of small purchases. To give this some historical perspective, this is actually nothing new. It might feel this way, but we are actually not the first generation to live through scary times. We probably won't be the last. And economic spending does increase in times of geopolitical uncertainty. There's also other interesting cases of how money responds to our emotions in uncertain times, some wacky examples.
衣橱，并通过小额购买获得多巴胺。从历史的角度来看，这其实并不是什么新鲜事。你可能会觉得这是个新现象，但我们其实并不是第一代经历可怕时期的人。我们大概也不会是最后一代。在充满地缘政治不确定性的时期，经济消费确实会增加。关于在不确定时期金钱如何回应我们的情绪，还有其他一些有趣的案例，一些古怪的例子。
One that we found was that in the 1800s, there was this Baptist preacher named William Miller and he had this huge following and he was like, guess what? Jesus is going to return in 1844. The world's going to end. The chosen few are going to ascend into heaven. And so let's live it up. You know, take out loans, build your dream house, buy nice dinners, buy the car you want. I don't know if they had cars in the 1800s.
我们发现的一个例子是，在19世纪，有一位名叫威廉·米勒（William Miller）的浸信会传教士，他拥有庞大的追随者群体，他说：“你们猜怎么着？耶稣将在1844年重返人间。世界末日要来了。被拣选的少数人将升入天堂。所以让我们尽情狂欢吧。你知道的，去贷款，建造你的梦想住宅，享用精美的晚餐，买你想要的汽车。”我不知道19世纪有没有汽车。
They definitely didn't. But you know what I mean? Like they were spending all this money so lavishly because they didn't think they would have to repay their debts. And then, you know, the logic was that the apocalypse was. so near, why not have fun now? And then the apocalypse didn't happen. And this whole community essentially went bankrupt. So we have seen examples of this in the past. You know, now, obviously, it's not a religious apocalypse. It's climate change. It's inflation. It's AI. It's the 24-hour news cycle. But the psychological pattern is the same. When the world feels unstable, we turn to
他们当然没有。但你知道我的意思吧？他们挥霍着所有的钱，因为他们认为自己不需要偿还债务。然后，当时的逻辑是，世界末日已经迫在眉睫，为什么现在不及时行乐呢？结果世界末日并没有发生。这个群体基本上破产了。所以我们在过去见过这样的例子。当然，现在这不再是宗教意义上的末日，而是气候变化、通货膨胀、人工智能、24小时循环新闻。但心理模式是一样的。当世界让人感到不稳定时，我们会转向
consumption as a way of asserting control because spending money is one of the only things that we can do that feels like it does something or gives us something back. And that's doom spending. Why is that the case? Why does spending money kind of feel empowering? Well, when we spend money, basically our dopamine system is activated. I feel like you guys already know that. But it's not just when we get the thing, it's when we see something we like, when we anticipate a purchase, when we click checkout, when we're waiting for the parcel to arrive, when we go and collect it, every single element of this process triggers the release of dopamine. And at all those various touch points, our mood is briefly improved and our stress is briefly lowered. Over time, we learn
消费作为一种宣示控制权的方式，因为花钱是我们能做的仅有的几件能让人觉得有所作为或能从中有回报的事情之一。这就是末日消费。为什么会这样呢？为什么花钱会让人觉得有一种赋权感呢？好吧，当我们花钱时，基本上我们的大脑多巴胺系统就被激活了。我觉得你们已经知道了这一点。但不仅是在我们得到物品的时候，当我们看到喜欢的东西时，当我们对购买有所期待时，当我们点击结账时，当我们等待包裹送达时，当我们去取快递时，这个过程中的每一个环节都会触发多巴胺的释放。在所有这些不同的接触点上，我们的情绪都会短暂改善，压力也会短暂减轻。随着时间的推移，我们通过
through association that we feel better from spending. We feel nice. And also, it's accessible to us. We get something in return. We get a good. We get an item. So psychologically, spending functions like an emotional regulation strategy, much like eating comfort food, much like scrolling social media.
关联学会了通过消费来感觉更好。我们感觉很好。而且，这对我们来说也很容易做到。我们能有所回报。我们得到了一件商品。所以从心理学上讲，消费就像是一种情绪调节策略，非常类似于吃慰藉食物，非常类似于刷社交媒体。
In cognitive behavioral terms, if we want to go really psychological, it is what we call negative reinforcement, the behavior, the act of buying of shopping removes distress and that's pleasurable and so it's more likely to be repeated. So the thing that we really need to note is that doom spending, yes, is tied up in materialism. It's not necessarily about materialism. It's about fear. It's about comfort. It's about control.
用认知行为学的术语来说，如果我们想深入探讨心理学的话，这就是我们所说的负面强化，消费或购物这种行为消除了痛苦，这带来了快感，因此这种行为更有可能重复。所以我们真正需要注意的是，末日消费确实与物质主义交织在一起。但它不一定与物质主义有关。它关乎恐惧。它关乎安慰。它关乎控制。
It's about feeling safe almost. Second, the evidence does really confirm. It's not just that, you know, we're a generation that has more money. It's not just that shopping is more accessible, that delivery is more accessible, that things come faster. Political and global context is driving overspending. Studies and financial reports show that impulse spending has rapidly increased since the pandemic.
它关乎一种安全感。其次，证据确实证实了这一点。不仅仅是因为我们这一代人更有钱了。不仅仅是因为购物更容易了，快递更容易了，东西送达得更快了。政治和全球背景正在推动过度消费。研究和财务报告显示，自大流行以来，冲动消费急剧增加。
And especially during the pandemic, that is when a lot of these habits were triggered. you know, online shopping was one of the very few joys we seem to have control over. I was so broke during the pandemic, so broke. And I used to spend $100. I remember I had like a little bit of money in my bank account from my restaurant job that I was obviously I didn't have. And I would spend like $100 on something and then I would return it and then I would buy something else and then I would return it.
特别是在大流行期间，许多这样的习惯就是在那个时候被触发的。你知道的，网上购物似乎是我们仅有的能够掌控的少数乐趣之一。我在大流行期间穷得叮当响，穷透了。我曾经花100美元。我记得我银行账户里有一点从餐馆打工赚来的钱，而这钱我显然本来不该花的。我会花100美元买个东西，然后退掉，接着再买点别的，然后又退掉。
I think I recycled that $100 like five times. I even remember like I bought this tartan puffer jacket. I don't know why. Like there was no weather that required me to buy that. And then I returned it and then I bought like basically something exactly the same and returned that because of the dopamine. And this is where a lot of us learnt this habit. According to 2023 data from the Federal Reserve Bank of New York,
我觉得我把那100美元循环利用了大概五次。我甚至还记得我买了一件格子呢羽绒服。我不知道为什么。当时根本没有任何天气需要我去买那个东西。然后我把它退了，接着又买了一件基本上完全一样的东西，然后又把它退了，就为了追求那个多巴胺。这就是我们很多人养成这个习惯的地方。根据纽约联邦储备银行2023年的数据，
credit card balances in the US rose in. 17% between 2020 and 2022. That is the sharpest increase in decades. Similar things happened in a lot of other countries where credit card data is like readily available. So in the UK, in Australia, across Europe, in Canada, across all these countries, we could see this trend. Psychologists who are studying, still studying post-pandemic consumer behavior,
美国的信用卡余额在2020年至2022年期间飙升了17%。这是几十年来最急剧的增长。在许多其他信用卡数据现成可查的国家，也发生了类似的情况。所以在英国、澳大利亚、整个欧洲、加拿大，在所有这些国家，我们都能看到这种趋势。正在研究（并且仍在研究）大流行后消费者行为的心理学家们，
that kind of sounds like a tongue twister, but post-pandemic consumer behavior, note that collective trauma, economic precarity, social isolation, basically what it's all created are these shorter planning horizons. The future feels bleak, it feels uncertain. And so we tend to not think that it's going to happen. When you ask people in their 20s or in their 30s, people our age, hey, like, how far do you think in the future? For me, it's probably only six months, and that's not normal. Like, you should be able to plan and think about your life long term, but I think the state of the world means that it's really hard to. Everything is changing so far. It's like, you just can't imagine the world beyond six months. So if you can't imagine the world
这听起来有点像绕口令，但大流行后的消费者行为表明，集体创伤、经济不稳定、社交隔离，基本上所有这些共同造就了较短的规划视界。未来让人感到黯淡，感到不确定。因此，我们往往认为未来不会发生了。当你问二十多岁或三十多岁的人，问我们这个年纪的人：“嘿，你觉得你会为多久以后做规划？”对我来说，可能只有六个月，这并不正常。你应该能够对自己的生活进行长远规划和思考，但我认为世界现状意味着这真的很难做到。一切变化都太快了。这就好像，你根本无法想象六个月以后的世界。所以如果你无法想象
in six months. Why are you going to save for a financial goal that's 10 years away? Like buying a house. Why are you going to save for a financial goal that's 50 years away or 40 years away? Like retirement. The appeal of this immediate gratification in the face of like really scary stuff often overshadows, you know, a more rational decision-making process that is reliant on us being able to imagine a future with us. in it. Another explanation, spending money is just a nice distraction. When you're thinking about when your parcel is going to arrive, when you're thinking about how this next outfit is going to change your life, you're not thinking about everything else that's going wrong. And this really aligns with like the infamous little treat narrative. Now, I'm a big fan of this. I love a little
六个月后的世界。你为什么还要为一个十年后的财务目标存钱呢？比如买房。你为什么还要为一个五十年后或四十年后的财务目标存钱呢？比如退休。面对这些极其可怕的事情，这种即时满足的诱惑往往会掩盖那些依赖于我们能否想象一个有我们存在的未来的更加理性的决策过程。另一种解释是，花钱只是一种很好的分心方式。当你思考你的包裹什么时候能送到，当你思考这套新衣服将如何改变你的生活时，你就不会去想其他所有正在出错的事情。这与臭名昭著的“小奖励”叙事不谋而合。现在，我是这个理念的超级粉丝。我喜欢小奖励。
treat. I'm a big believer in little treats. It's not inherently bad. It's not inherently bad. add to treat yourself. And I actually think it's, you know, an important part of self-care and self-comfort. But when treat culture turns into habitual high spend behavior, especially when it's triggered by fear or anxiety, that's a coping mechanism, not a reward. And add that to the fact that nowadays like companies and the global economy and, you know, big brands are taking advantage of that, is it really about us or is it being manipulated for profit? The other day I was in Sydney driving to the airport and I saw this massive billboard that was like from McDonald's and it said existing question mark, you deserve a little tree. That's, that's a marketing cost. That's a marketing
我非常坚信“小奖励”的力量。这本身并没有什么坏处。犒劳自己并没有什么坏处。而且我实际上认为，这是自我照顾和自我安慰的重要组成部分。但当奖励文化演变成习惯性的大额消费行为，尤其是当它由恐惧或焦虑引发时，那这就是一种应对机制，而不是一种奖励。再加上如今许多公司、全球经济以及各大品牌都在利用这一点，这真的是为了我们好吗，还是说我们为了利润而被操纵了？有一天我在悉尼开车去机场，我看到一个巨大的麦当劳广告牌，上面写着：“存在吗，问号。你应得一个精美小礼品。”这，这是一笔营销费用。这是一笔营销，
Like, that is not self-care. That is McDonald's trying to get you to buy the thing that they have designed for you to spend money to fill their pockets. And especially nowadays when we are bombarded with targeted ads, we are streamlined into buy now buttons and limited time offers and sales. I think the shift from reward to regulation can happen really subtly and is impacting a lot of us. that's impacting me for sure. You know, there really is something to be said about doom spending, the fact that so many people in their 20s are spending more money than they probably have,
这根本不是什么自我照顾。那是麦当劳试图诱使你购买他们设计好让你花钱以填满他们腰包的东西。尤其是现在，当我们被狂轰滥炸的目标广告包围时，我们被引导至“立即购买”按钮、限时优惠和促销活动中。我认为从奖励到调节的转变可以非常微妙地发生，并且正在影响着我们很多人。这绝对在影响着我。你知道的，关于末日消费确实有很多话可说，成千上万的二十多岁年轻人花出去的钱可能比他们实际拥有的还要多，
and the role of technology and social media. Think about the last time you scrolled your Instagram feed. You will see news of genocide, news of political unrest, news of climate disasters. And then what happens after that? Add for a designer bag. We can get away. pair of sneakers, phone case, sweater, t-shirt, buy now, buy now, buy now.
以及技术和社交媒体所扮演的角色。想想你上次刷Instagram动态的时候。你会看到关于种族灭绝的新闻、政治动荡的新闻、气候灾难的新闻。然后在那之后发生了什么？名牌包的广告。我们可以逃避。一双运动鞋、手机壳、毛衣、T恤，“立即购买，立即购买，立即购买”。
That's emotional whiplash. You are going from panic and despair to pleasure and intrigue. And that is not accidental, it's engineered. Social media platforms, and there have been articles on this, there have been people who have come out, who were involved in making these systems, who have come out and said, we designed it this way. They are made to monetize your attention because when ads make money, they make money. And the way ads make money is if the site holds your attention long enough to trigger an emotion that will produce a sale. Fear, outrage, sadness, whatever it is, these all heightened arousal.
这就是情绪上的急转直下。你从恐慌和绝望瞬间切换到愉悦和好奇。这不是偶然的，这是精心设计出来的。社交媒体平台——并且已经有关于这方面的文章发表，有些曾参与制造这些系统的人也站出来说——我们就是这样设计的。它们旨在将你的注意力变现，因为当广告赚钱时，它们就能赚钱。而广告赚钱的方式，就是让网站留住你的注意力足够长的时间，以触发能够产生销售的情绪。恐惧、愤怒、悲伤，无论是什么，这些都会加剧唤醒状态。
They keep us scrolling more and more. And once you're in that heightened emotional state, once your defenses are lowered, once the world feels terrible, you're more suggestible, you're more reward-seeking, you're more likely to act impulsively. The discomfort we feel when we flip between threat and reward, like, requires an antidote. We want a solution. We want to feel better. And then this algorithm, these social media platforms, they serve it right up to us. A 2024 study by researchers in Indonesia found that exposure to emotionally charged content significantly increased impulse buying in people in their 20s, in young adults.
它们让我们不停地刷屏。一旦你处于那种高度情绪化的状态，一旦你的防线降低，一旦世界感觉糟糕透顶，你就更容易接受暗示，更容易寻求奖励，更有可能做出冲动的行为。我们在威胁和奖励之间切换时感到了不适，这需要解药。我们想要一个解决方案。我们想要感觉好一点。然后这个算法，这些社交媒体平台，就把这些直接送到了我们面前。印尼研究人员在2024年进行的一项研究发现，接触充满情绪色彩的内容会显著增加二十多岁年轻人和年轻成人的冲动购买。
essentially after being emotionally activated, people were more likely to buy stuff. And when they were asked why, oftentimes they couldn't really explain it. So this is when spending because you want something, spending because you do deserve a little treat and spending because you don't really know why you're spending and because it's a form of coping and emotional regulation, this is when the line really begins to blur. and what began as harmless distraction as actually filling a need. Like you do need clothes and you do need things in your life can quietly turn into like a routine, an addiction, a really toxic habit.
本质上，在情绪被激活后，人们更有可能买东西。而当被问及原因时，他们往往无法真正解释清楚。所以，当你为了想要某样东西而消费、因为觉得自己确实应得一个小奖励而消费，以及因为你并不真正知道自己为什么要消费、因为它是一种应对和情绪调节的形式而消费时，这条界限就开始真正变得模糊了。原本作为无害分流的东西，实际上是在填补某种需求。就像你确实需要衣服，你确实需要生活中的物品一样，它可能会悄悄演变成一种常规、一种瘾、一种真正有毒的习惯。
So let's talk about the signs that your doom spending might be going too far. And what you can do about it after this short break? 2%. That is the number of people who take the state. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
接下来我们聊聊末日消费可能已经失控的迹象。以及在这段短暂的广告休息之后，你能做些什么来应对它。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及建立复原力的科学。
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界里。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以超越主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little count?
我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊恐不安的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一边迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。也就是TWO percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆（Lil Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
嗯，你可以在Look Back at It播客中找到答案。我是Sam J.，我是Alex English。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期节目，我们邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时准备在白天谈论快克，只是为了让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们讨论快克的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at It。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我所谈论的是。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it, and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses.
特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求事物的过程中，我们过于专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐，却不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。
Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要？还是你当好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去当一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，与我凯尔·盖恩斯（Keir Gaines）一起，就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标进行真实的对话。
Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself. at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a year's long court battle to prove the truth.
打开免费的I Heart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这就引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我只篡改了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Michael Sbian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。迈克尔·斯比安（Michael Sbian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我当时惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，千万不要招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也千万不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在新一季的《The Girlfriend》中，“噢天哪，这就是同一个人。”一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends.
我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在乎。所以他们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。请收听《The Girlfriends》。
Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So how do you know when treating yourself has tipped into something else entirely? most of us don't wake up one morning and think like, oh no, I have developed an unhealthy coping mechanism. What will I do about this? Like it really creeps in slowly. It's disguised again as fun as keeping up with trends. But here are the signs that it's gone a little bit too far. Firstly, you notice that your biggest shopping days aren't actually when you need anything,
相信我，宝贝。请在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。那么，你如何知道犒劳自己何时已经完全演变成了别的东西呢？我们大多数人不会在某个早晨醒来，然后想：“噢不，我养成了不健康的应对机制。我该怎么处理这事呢？”这其实是悄悄潜入的。它再次伪装成乐趣，伪装成紧跟潮流。但以下是它有些过头的迹象。首先，你注意到你最大的购物日其实并不是在你需要什么东西的时候，
aren't when you've just gotten paid, aren't when you're celebrating. They actually are when you're anxious, when you're overwhelmed or you're sad. Especially if you are shopping a lot at night. Big red flag. Inhibitions are lowered. Often that's when our biggest feelings come about. We're tired from the day. Shopping is the Band-Aid.
不是在你刚发工资的时候，也不是在庆祝的时候。它们实际上是在你感到焦虑、不知所措或难过的时候。特别是如果你在夜间频繁网购。这是一个巨大的危险信号。自我克制力减弱了。通常那是我们情绪最强烈的时候。我们白天很累。购物成了创可贴。
Secondly, this one's the obvious one. You're spending beyond your means. And you're seriously spending beyond your means. You know, a huge thing that has boomed in recent years is these buy-in-hour pay later, buy-in-for, delayed payment options, even using credit. credit cards to pay for small things that aren't necessities also comes under this. Now, I don't think these kinds of options are inherently bad at all. To be honest, I use Clana. I use like the PayPal for in, I don't know what it is, like the four payment things, especially because I don't get paid regularly.
其次，显而易见的一点是。你的消费超出了你的能力范围。而且你是严重超出了你的能力范围。你知道的，近年来大火的一个趋势是“先买后付”、分期付款、延迟付款选项，甚至使用信用卡。信用卡来支付不是必需品的小额开销也属于这一范畴。现在，我并不认为这类选项本身有多么糟糕。说实话，我也用Klarna。我用类似PayPal分四期付款的东西，我也不知道那叫什么，就是那个四次付款的功能，特别是因为我的收入不是规律发放的。
It like helps me break up my budget. And I used to use it when I was working as a consultant and I got paid monthly just to kind of like make the things I was repaying for weekly and monthly as well. I think they offer flexibility, but they also allow you to go a little bit too far. Behavioral economists have highlighted that separating the payment from the consumption reduces what we call the pain of pain. This is a concept that was coined in the 90s, and the pain of paying is an important part of the buying process and is basically the psychological discomfort that makes us hesitate before a purchase. When we use later pay options, it delays or disguises the payment. So our brain feels like it can
它帮我分解了我的预算。以前当我作为顾问工作、按月领薪水时，我也用它，只是为了让我每周和每月需要偿还的东西分摊开来。我认为它们提供了灵活性，但也让你有点走得太远了。行为经济学家强调，将支付与消费分离会减少我们所谓的“支付的痛苦”。这是一个在90年代创造的概念，“支付的痛苦”是购买过程中的一个重要部分，基本上就是那种在购买前让我们犹豫不决的心理不适感。当我们使用“稍后付款”选项时，它会延迟或掩饰支付过程。所以我们的大脑会觉得它可以
experience all of the rewards and none or a fraction of the cost until later on. That is the danger. And again, they're not necessarily bad. They're not all bad. But what it does have the potential to slip into is chasing payments, slipping into debt, if they are used for things to pay for things that are beyond our means. Even if you want to use these platforms to pay for your shopping, you have to ensure that you actually have the money there to use it if you needed to. And that's how you prevent the cost from stacking up when, you know, you have no other way to pay for these or when the payments are due. I think something really related to this that shows doom spending has gone too far for you is if you found yourself deliberately ignoring bank statements, deliberately
体验所有的回报，而直到以后才付出全部或一小部分的成本。这就是危险所在。再说一次，它们不一定都是坏的，也不是全都坏的。但如果将它们用于支付超出我们能力范围的东西，它确实有可能滑向追逐还款和陷入债务的深渊。即使你想用这些平台来支付你的购物费用，你也必须确保如果你真的需要的话，你手头其实是有这笔钱来用的。这就是如何防止成本不断累积的方法，当你知道自己没有其他方式来支付这些费用，或者当账单到期的时候。我认为与此密切相关、表明你的末日消费已经过头的现象是，如果你发现自己故意忽视银行对账单，故意
ignoring notifications, feeling a sense of dread when you open your banking app. Financial avoidance is a huge red flag and a huge coping mechanism that a lot of us in our 20s have because your brain is trying to shield you from all the fear and shame and the guilt and just keep all the good stuff, keep all the purchases, keep all the dopamine. But that cycle actually makes everything get worse. You're no longer aware of how much is coming in and out of your account each week. You don't know how much you really need to live. At first, it's the easier option to just not look.
忽视通知，在打开银行App时感到一阵恐惧。财务回避是一个巨大的危险信号，也是我们许多二十多岁的人都在使用的一种应对机制，因为你的大脑正试图保护你免受所有的恐惧、羞耻和内疚的侵扰，只想保留所有美好的东西，保留所有的购物，保留所有的多巴胺。但这种循环实际上让一切变得更糟。你不再清楚每周有多少钱流入和流出你的账户。你不知道自己真正需要多少钱来生活。起初，不去看似乎是最简单的选择。
But I promise you, I have done that when I, again, when I was working as a consultant, I had terrible financial habits, which is ironic. Having financial accountability, even if you really have to stare, your shopping and you're spending straight in the face, is so much better for you long term. So if you have recognized this pattern in yourself, how do you stop? Now, I'm not going to say, like, swear off spending altogether, go cold turkey, never works, I don't think it's realistic. It's like telling yourself never to eat sugar again.
但我向你保证，我以前也这么做过，当我——同样是在做顾问的时候，我有糟糕的财务习惯，这很具有讽刺意味。建立财务责任感，哪怕你真的必须直视你的购物和消费，从长远来看对你来说要好得多。因此，如果你在自己身上意识到了这种模式，你该如何停下来呢？现在，我不会说什么“发誓彻底戒掉消费，直接冷火鸡式戒除”，这从来不管用，我觉得这不现实。这就好比告诉自己再也不吃糖了。
You're going to eat sugar by like Tuesday. Instead, the goal is to retrain your brain, to replace emotional spending with more sustainable forms of regulation and of control. So here are a few tips of like how to start, how to do that. First, let's flip it around. If doom spending is about spending because the future feels uncertain, doom saving is about saving because it feels uncertain. It's like a little way to create a sense of safety and a sense of the future in a very small, very tangible way.
到了周二你还是会吃糖的。相反，我们的目标是重新训练你的大脑，用更具可持续性的调节和控制形式来取代情感消费。所以这里有一些关于如何开始、如何做到的技巧。首先，让我们扭转一下思维。如果末日消费是因为未来感觉不确定而消费，那么末日储蓄就是因为未来感觉不确定而储蓄。这是一种以非常微小、非常具体的方式来创造安全感和未来感的小方法。
You don't have to start with huge amounts. Actually, research always shows us small, consistent, you know, saving goals. is key, five or $10 a week, it actually increases your sense of confidence in your own ability to manage money, but also feelings of psychological well-being and feelings of self-trust. Like, hey, like, I'm proud of this. I'm taking this thing that I earned that I worked hard for, and I'm building something for my future. And the very fact that it's there has this weird reverse way of telling you that there will
你不需要从巨额资金开始。事实上，研究总是表明，小额、持续的储蓄目标才是关键。每周存5美元或10美元，这实际上会增强你对自己管理金钱能力的信心，同时也会提升心理幸福感和自我信任感。就像，“嘿，我为这感到骄傲。我拿着这笔我赚来的、我努力工作得来的钱，正在为我的未来建立一些东西。”而它就摆在那里的这个事实，有一种奇怪的逆向方式在告诉你，将来还会有
be a future, which is really what we're trying to get down to at the end of the day. behavioral economist Richard Thaler, he called this approach mental accounting, reframing savings not as deprivation, but as a reward, as an act of self-care, as an act of self-trust, as an act of, yeah, future investment. Like you're saving for the life that one day you're going to really love and enjoy. And this really counters the idea that we explored earlier of temporal discounting or present bias because the future feels are so uncertain, you know, we spend more money now. But if we save more, the possibilities for the future, the trip we're saving for the dream
一个未来，这其实是我们归根结底想要达到的目的。行为经济学家理查德·塞勒（Richard Thaler）将这种方法称之为心理账户，将储蓄重新定义为一种剥夺，而是一种奖励，一种自我关爱、自我信任的行动，是一种对未来投资的行动。就像你是在为你某天会真正热爱和享受的生活存钱。这就反驳了我们之前探讨过的“时间贴现”或“现时偏差”的概念，因为未来感觉如此不确定，所以我们现在花更多的钱。但如果我们存更多的钱，未来的可能性——我们为之攒钱的旅行、梦想中的
house, they expand. I found this incredibly interesting article published in 2011 in the Journal of Marketing Research that found across four studies. Participants who were basically asked to interact with realistic computer-generated simulations of their future selves using virtual technology were more likely to accept a larger sum of money down the line. So just to like roll that back, they got all these people, these participants, and they put them in these simulations, they let them create these simulations of like a really beautiful future and they were really realistic and then they said, oh hey, by the way,
房子——就会扩展开来。我发现了一篇极其有趣的论文，它于2011年发表在《营销研究杂志》（Journal of Marketing Research）上，其中通过四项研究发现：那些被要求利用虚拟技术与自己未来模特的逼真电脑生成模拟形象进行互动的参与者，更有可能接受未来更大金额的钱。所以简单回顾一下，他们找来所有人，这些参与者，把他们放到这些模拟场景中，让他们创造关于真正美好未来的模拟形象，而且它们非常逼真，然后他们说：“哦，嘿，顺便说一句，
you actually get paid for this. Would you want $50? now or do you want me to give you $100 at the end of the term or $100 in three months? And the people who had seen these really positive versions of themselves and whose futures seemed really happy and bright, they wanted to wait. In all cases, they wanted to accept the later monetary reward over the immediate one. And I just think, I love this study. It really brilliantly demonstrates that keeping that future self in mind, forcing yourself to really imagine them when making these financial decisions,
你实际上会为此得到报酬。你现在想要50美元，还是希望我在学期结束时给你100美元，或者在三个月后给你100美元？”那些看到了这些非常积极的自我版本、且他们的未来看起来非常幸福光明的人，他们愿意等待。在所有情况下，他们都宁愿接受稍后的金钱奖励，也不愿接受眼前的即时奖励。我只是觉得，我喜欢这项研究。它非常精彩地证明了，在做这些财务决策时，将那个未来的自己铭记在心，迫使自己真正去想象他们，
when going to buy stuff, goes a long way. Next, the next tip that we can really do for ourselves is just reallocate where your money goes. Psychological research consistently finds that spending on experiences rather than material goods, like a new top or a new pair of shoes, leads to greater and longer lasting happiness. Why? Because experiences connect to identity and experiences connect to relationships and experiences connect to a deep sense of memory and sense of self and sense of interconnectedness. Spending on experiences as well, builds stories, gives you stories, gives you memories that make you excited for future memories and they give you something that's going to last
在准备买东西时，会大有帮助。接下来，我们可以为自己做的下一个技巧就是重新分配你的钱去向何方。心理学研究一再发现，将钱花在经历上，而不是物质商品（比如一件新上衣或一双新鞋）上，会带来更大、更持久的幸福感。为什么？因为经历与身份相连，经历与人际关系相连，经历与对深度记忆、自我感以及相互联系感的感知相连。将钱花在经历上，也能构建故事，为你提供故事，提供能让你对未来的记忆感到兴奋的记忆，并且它们会给你带来比塑料和杂物持久得多、
a lot longer than plastic and a lot longer than clutter. And like, don't get me wrong. I love things. I love clothes. I love buying stuff. I have so many purchases that are just stupid that I still really, really value. But are they going to be the things I take with me? No, I literally can't.
长久得多的东西。而且，别误会我的意思。我喜欢物品。我喜欢衣服。我喜欢买东西。我有那么多毫无意义的购买，但我依然非常非常珍视它们。但它们会是我带进坟墓的东西吗？不，我根本带不走。
But buying the concert ticket, doing the day trip, spending a little bit of extra money so that we can, you know, get a nice place on the girls weekend. Like those things really anchor me. anchor us in memory and in belonging and they are a great great way to form novel and exciting experiences that just makes life worth and feel worth living. Another way, I'm full of tips today. Another way to begin reallocating your spending that I do is I create and I have created a 24 hour rule.
但是买一张音乐会门票，来一次一日游，多花一点小钱，这样我们就可以，你知道的，在闺蜜周末找个好地方。就像这些事情真的能让我内心安定，让我们在记忆和归属感中安定下来，它们是形成新颖和刺激体验的绝佳方式，这让生活值得拥有，也让人觉得生活值得过下去。还有一种方法，我今天有很多小建议。我做的重新分配开支的另一种方法是，我创建并建立了一个24小时规则。
And friends of mine have seen me use this. They can tell you it works. When I see something I want, I do not buy it right away. I'm allowed to buy it eventually. but I have to wait minimum 24 hours. I get my notes up on my phone. I write it down. I write down the item, the price, the date I initially wanted to buy it.
我的朋友们见过我用这个。他们可以告诉你这很管用。当我看到想要的东西时，我不会马上买。我最终还是可以买的，但我必须等至少24小时。我在手机上打开便签，把它写下来。我写下物品、价格、我最初想买的日期。
Then I just let it sit. This short delay activates what psychologists call system to thinking. That slower, more deliberate part of your brain that handles logic and that handles long-term reasoning, when you give the impulsive part of your brain, pause, this system to, this second system, locks in and allows you to like spend better, it's been in more alignment with your values. Most of the time, you will find that the desire fades once the emotional charge passes. And if it doesn't, then you know the purchase actually matters to you. It's more intentional. It's not reactive. Like I said, I've done this for years. I keep a want to buy list.
然后我就把它放在那儿。这种短暂的延迟激活了心理学家所说的系统二思考。那是你大脑中较慢、更深思熟虑的部分，它处理逻辑，处理长期推理，当你给大脑中冲动的部分按下暂停键时，这个系统二，即第二个系统，就会启动，让你能够更好地消费，这与你的价值观更加一致。大多数情况下，你会发现一旦情绪过去，这种欲望就会消退。如果没有，那么你就知道这个购买对你来说真的很重要。它更有意图，而不是反应性的。就像我说的，我这样做很多年了。我保留了一份待买清单。
on my phone and in preparation for this episode, I was like, what have I got on there? I haven't actually looked all the way back for a little while. I just add things on. I cannot even remember putting some of these things on the list. One of them was like white abacrumbie jeans. I've literally listed them here. An Imogen and Willie shirt, what even is that? Like, I don't, I'm sure it's great. Imogen and Willie. I'm sure you make great shirts. Like, but I don't know what that is. This print that says love is a kiss on the forehead super cute i don't know what that print looks like i'm sure it's great but like i didn't need it there was another thing that was on there was a garnie keychain that was three hundred dollars like what i think that was when like everybody was doing
在我的手机上，为了准备这一期节目，我想：我上面有什么？我其实有一段时间没有一直往前翻了。我只是往上加东西。我甚至记不清自己是怎么把其中一些东西加到清单上的。其中一个就像是白色的阿伯克比牛仔裤。我甚至把它们列在这里了。一件伊莫根和威利衬衫，那到底是什么？就像，我不知道，我确信它很好。伊莫根和威利。我确信你们做了很棒的衬衫。就像，但我不知道那是什么。这个上面写着“爱是在额头上的一个吻”的印花超级可爱，我不知道那个印花长什么样，我确信它很好，但像我不需要它。还有另一件在上面的东西是一个加尼钥匙扣，要三百美元。就像什么，我想那是当每个人都在做
those like trinkets on the bag situation which i love i got into it but like 300 dollars like that's so much money that's so much money and like i was looking at that i was like thank god i didn't buy that. That distance, like, provided some clarity. It has saved me. I think I did like a little calculation of like five things and it was like totaling over $1,200 just because I waited, just because I had this list. There is, of course, other ways of going about this. I have a friend who, and I'm just going to give her a shout out because she said she was going to do this at the start of the year. It is, what is it, like November now and she's still doing it. She is, only allowed to buy secondhand goods for the whole year unless it's like underwear. And I cannot
那些包包上的小饰品的时候，我很喜欢，我也参与进去了，但是300美元，天哪，那是好多钱，那是好多钱，然后我看着那个，我想：谢天谢地我没买。那种距离感，带来了一些清晰度。它拯救了我。我想我大概算了一下五样东西，总共超过了1200美元，仅仅因为我等了，仅仅因为我有了这个清单。当然，还有其他方法可以做到这一点。我有一个朋友，我要在这里向她大声致意，因为她说她要在年初的时候这样做。现在是，现在是什么时候，大概十一月了吧，她还在这样做。她整个一年都只能买二手商品，除非是内衣之类的。我无法
tell you the amount of times that I'm not going to lie. I low-key wanted her to break the pact. I wanted her to promise to myself, I'm sorry Emma, but like she, because you know, something looks really cute on her or whatever, but she genuinely like has stuck to it. Her depot purchases are amazing. Like she's doing so well and I just like feel like that's another system where it's like you're allowed to buy. You're allowed to spend. You do so more sustainably. Another friend of mine, albeit I will say she lives with her boyfriend. They don't have much space, but they have the one in one out rule.
告诉你我有多少次，说实话，我暗地里希望她打破这个契约。我希望她对自己许诺，对不起艾玛，但她因为你知道的，有些东西穿在她身上真的很可爱或者别的什么，但她真的坚持下来了。她Depot的购买记录太棒了。她做得太好了，我只是觉得那是另一个系统，你被允许购买。你被允许消费。你这样做更加可持续。我的另一个朋友，虽然我得说她和她男朋友住在一起。他们没有太多空间，但他们有一进一出原则。
So she can buy stuff, but she has to get rid of something. And she has a great closet. She has a full closet. But it really allows her to be conscious of what is really reflecting me. what do I really want to spend my money on? Is there anything that like, is this really going to bring me value? I'm going to wear this enough that I should throw something out or I should donate something?
所以她可以买东西，但她必须扔掉一些东西。她有一个很棒的衣橱。她有一个满满的衣橱。但这确实让她能够意识到什么才是真正反映我的东西？我到底想把钱花在什么上面？有没有什么东西，这真的能给我带来价值吗？我穿它的次数够多，以至于我应该扔掉点什么或者捐掉点什么？
It sounds simple, but it's a subtle form of what we call a commitment device, a behavioral nudge, a behavioral rule that adds accountability and that reminds you that every purchase does have a cost beyond money. It costs you space, it costs you attention, it costs you your emotional bandwidth as well. And I think it also allows you to build a sense of identity through intentional ownership. Like your life is not a trend.
这听起来很简单，但它是我们所谓的承诺机制的一种微妙形式，一种行为助推，一种增加问责制并提醒你的行为规则，即每次购买除了金钱之外确实都有成本。它会消耗你的空间，消耗你的注意力，也会消耗你的情感带宽。而且我认为它也让你通过有意识的所有权建立一种身份感。就像你的生活不是一种潮流。
Your emotions are not trendified, right? You can't let your emotions be the thing that determines who you're going to be because you spend money to soothe them. You really develop a sense of personal style, develop a sense of a personal brand, you really develop a sense of like personal money values that is so so powerful i think what we're really talking about here is just mindful consumption slowing down having a sense of intention being deliberate about what you fill your life with so many studies say our physical possessions impact our
你的情绪不是潮流化的，对吧？你不能让情绪来决定你将成为什么样的人，因为你花钱是为了安抚它们。你真正培养出一种个人风格感，培养出一种个人品牌感，你真正培养出一种个人的金钱价值观，这是非常非常强大的。我认为我们在这里真正讨论的只是正念消费，慢下来，有意识感，对你生活中充实的内容保持深思熟虑。太多的研究表明，我们的物质财产会影响我们的
mindset and our psychology so don't just like fill up your space with shit you don't need and stuff that like isn't important to you because then your life's going to feel unimportant and your environment's going to feel cluttered and it's not going to feel like yours. Finally, one of the biggest tips to help you with your doom spending increase the pain of paying. One of the reasons spending has become so automatic is that you don't have to put in your credit card details. You don't have to hand over cash. The other day I bought my friend this, I just said to do the mental math, this episode will be out after her birthday. But for her birthday, I bought her like this really beautiful, I guess, like bathrobe,
心态和心理，所以不要只是用你不需要的垃圾和对你不重要的事情来填满你的空间，因为那样你的生活就会变得不重要，你的环境就会变得杂乱，而且不会让你觉得那是你自己的。最后，帮助你摆脱厄运式消费的最大秘诀之一：增加支付痛苦。消费变得如此自动化的原因之一是你不必输入信用卡详细信息。你不必交出现金。前几天我给我朋友买了这个，我只是在脑子里算了一下，这期节目会在她生日后播出。但为了她的生日，我给她买了一个非常漂亮的，我想，就像浴袍一样，
like beach towel robe that she wanted for her birthday. And it literally took me less than a minute to buy it to the point where I was like, oh, is that, was, did I actually purchase that? And it was like, yeah, I did. No friction. No friction. We need to reintroduce the pain of pain, the sting that stops us for. spending. Delete your saved cards on your phone. Turn off Apple Pay. Turn off your one click checkout.
她生日想要的那种海滩毛巾长袍。我花不到一分钟的时间就买了下来，以至于我都觉得：哦，那是，我真的买了吗？然后就像：是的，我买。没有摩擦。没有摩擦。我们需要重新引入痛苦的痛苦，那个阻止我们消费的刺痛感。删除手机上保存的卡片。关闭Apple Pay。关闭一键结账。
Use cash. These small bits of friction make you purchase conscious, make you money conscious before you click by. Like there's just a couple more seconds where you have to really like you have to go find your card. You have to punch in your details. That delay. Again, It gives you, it gives your brain, your rational brain, a chance to catch up and a chance to be like, hey, wait, do I actually need this? You know, is this actually useful? What impulse am I trying to suppress here? When it takes energy to buy something, you have time to reevaluate, you have time to
使用现金。这些微小的摩擦让你在点击购买之前就有意识地去消费，有意识地去对待金钱。就像只需再多花几秒钟，你真的必须去找到你的卡。你必须输入你的详细信息。这种延迟。同样，它给了你，给了你的大脑，你的理性大脑一个赶上的机会，并有机会说：嘿，等等，我真的需要这个吗？你知道，这真的有用吗？我在这里试图压抑什么冲动？当购买某样东西需要消耗精力时，你就有时间重新评估，你就有时间
realign it with being intentional, with adding value to your life, with spending according to your values. And I think that just makes you a much more powerful person and it gives you a much more strong, much more strong mindset and even sense of personal identity. It goes quite deep. So to wrap up this episode, I think what doom spending really reveals is so much more than materialism and consumption. I think it's so easy for people to be like, you're just consumerist and like you're just
将其与有意识、为生活增添价值、根据自己的价值观消费重新对齐。我认为这会让你成为一个更有力量的人，并赋予你更强大、更强的心态，甚至是个人身份感。这相当深奥。所以为了总结这一期节目，我认为厄运式消费真正揭示的远不止是物质主义和消费主义。我认为人们很容易说：你只是个消费主义者，而且你只是
spending money. It's like, no, this is about a sense of control. We have, in our 20s right now, you and me, our generation, do you know, like, do you ever just sit down and realize what we have lived through, the amount of like history defying events that have occurred in our lifetime. And we have to read about it or see it or are exposed to it constantly. Of course your brain wants something certain. Even if that certainty, the only way you can get it is like a parcel at the front door. That is for some of us like the best we can do right now. And so there's no shame if that is something that you've relied on. There's no.
在花钱。这就像，不，这是关于一种控制感。我们现在二十几岁，你和我，我们这一代人，你知道，就像，你有没有坐下来意识到我们经历过什么，在我们的一生中发生了多少颠覆历史的事件。我们不得不去阅读它、看到它或不断接触它。当然你的大脑想要某种确定性的东西。即使这种确定性，你唯一能得到的途径就是门口的一个包裹。对我们中的一些人来说，那是我们现在能做到的最好的事。所以，如果你一直依赖这种东西，也没什么好羞耻的。没有什么。
shame if like sometimes like going on a shop going on a spree like buying stuff makes you feel better I just want you to know about it and I just want you to think about whether that's actually what you want from what you want from your life and if you want to keep spending the way that you are if deep down you know it might be a problem you know I think this is like guys let's get really deep it's the psychology of your 20s in a nutshell this is about learning how to sit with uncertainty without letting it rule you. Recognizing when we're trying to fill psychological, mental, emotional gaps with things and just gently redirecting. So thank you. Thank you for listening if you've made it this far. I like to do this thing. You guys know at the end of my episodes were like to reward your attention
羞耻，如果有时像去逛街、疯狂购物、买东西能让你感觉好点的话。我只是想让你知道这一点，我只是想让你思考这是否真的是你对生活的要求，如果你想继续保持现在的消费方式，如果内心深处你知道这可能是一个问题，你知道，我认为这就像，伙计们，让我们深入探讨一下，简而言之，这就是二十多岁的心理学，这是关于学习如何与不确定性共存，而不让它统治你。认识到当我们试图用物质填补心理、精神、情感空白时，并温柔地进行引导。所以谢谢你们。谢谢你们听到了这里。我喜欢做这件事。你们都知道在我的节目结束时，我们会奖励你的注意力
span and to reward you for listening. You get the like secret code for the episode. So today, if you made it this far, what is something currently on your buy list that you are putting off buying? Is it white jeans? Is it a $300 garning key chain? I don't know. Drop it down below. What are you currently thinking about buying? How much is it? Do you need it or not? I want to hear what's on everybody's list. Not in a way that's like to encourage people to buy them. I just like, I just want to know for curiosity. I want to thank our research assistant Libby Colbert for her. contributions to this episode. She's a hero. She is a champion and we love her. Also, make sure that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast. It's December coming up.
广度，并奖励你收听。你得到了这期节目的秘密代码。所以今天，如果你坚持到了这里，你购买清单上目前有什么东西是你一直推迟购买的？是白色的牛仔裤吗？是一个300美元的加尼钥匙扣吗？我不知道。在下面留言吧。你目前在考虑买什么？多少钱？你需要它还是不需要？我想听听每个人的清单上有什么。不是为了鼓励人们购买。我只是，出于好奇我只想知道。我要感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对
And you know what that means? It means guest month. Yes, that's right. A whole month, just of guests, just of really cool people that I got to talk to. So if you want to know who's going to be on the show, make sure you're following us over there or that you're following us slash subscribed, wherever you are listening to this episode. Again, Again, I appreciate you listening. I appreciate you giving us a five-star review on your support for the podcast. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, spend consciously. And we will talk very, very soon.
本期节目的贡献。她是个英雄。她是个冠军，我们爱她。另外，请确保在Instagram上关注我们：that psychology podcast。12月就要来了。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
你知道这意味着什么吗？这意味着嘉宾月。是的，没错。整整一个月，全都是嘉宾，全都是我可以交谈的非常酷的人。所以如果你想知道谁会出现在节目中，确保你在那边关注我们，或者无论你在哪里收听本期节目，都关注/订阅我们。再次，再次，感谢你的收听。感谢你在播客中给我们五星好评和支持。直到下一次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己好一点，有意识地消费。我们很快就会再聊。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是我的一个重要时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每集我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、喜剧同仁以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
那是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？您正在收听由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全进行的诚实对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起进行的。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰奇尼（Michael Ranchini）。我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。
That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends, trust me, babe,
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这是当电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《TWO.%》。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends》，相信我，宝贝，